ukraine dominated monday's summit and
strategic dialogue between top u.s and
indian officials that's because despite
nearly seven weeks of war delhi has
refused to condemn moscow's decision to
invade or back international efforts to
hold it accountable whether via
sanctions or suspension from the u.n
human rights council
before the cameras u.s president joe
biden and indian prime minister narendra
modi were quick to agree
civilians are paying the highest price
including in bucha and kramatorsk
we immediately condemned it and we
demanded an independent inquiry we hope
that the talks going on between ukraine
and russia
will lead to peace i want to welcome
india's humanitarian support for the
people of ukraine
who are suffering a horrific assault
including a tragic shelling on a train
station last week that killed dozens of
innocent children and women and
civilians attempting to flee the
violence white house aides called biden
and modi's conversation candid but they
also said biden did not make any demands
of modi
the situation is complicated
delhi has a robust relationship with
moscow dating back to the cold war
despite the bush administration's launch
of a security partnership with india in
2005 the u.s has never replaced russia
as india's main weapons vendor and it's
only now that the u.s is promising to
help india find more sources of oil and
gas for its 1.4 billion citizens
what's more the u.s needs india a member
of the quad to help it check china's
expansionist goals so diplomatic
pressure has to be carefully applied
for india being neutral is what its
foreign policy interests require
we watch what's happening in the world
like any country does and we draw our
conclusions and make our assessments
and believe me we have a decent sense of
what is in our interest and know how to
protect it and advance it the us's view
india's relationship with
russia
was developed over decades
at a time when the united states was not
able
to be a partner to india
times have changed so even after a day
of high-level meetings between the u.s
and india a lot of questions remain
is the u.s willing to cut off one of its
partners against china because it won't
cut off russia
is india willing to undercut its moral
standing in the world because it refuses
to make economic and military plans with
a country other than russia
and ultimately what does any of this
have to do with the future of ukraine
rosalind jordan al jazeera the state
department